and welcome to hannity tonight we start
with a fox news alert we have a lot of
new news for you tonight now on this
program we have long detailed the hyper
partisan illegitimate nature of this
sham january 6 committee now on ongoing
in the d.c sewer and swamp but over the
past 48 hours the charade has been
exposed for all to see now after
yesterday's frankly ludicrous testimony
no one in their right mind should take
this committee seriously it has been
apparent from day one this committee
always had a predetermined outcome and
every single person on the committee we
all know voted to impeach trump and
hates donald trump and what we all
witnessed was so blatantly dishonest so
unethical that the members of the
committee well they should be ashamed of
themselves although we all know they
have no shame
nor do their cheerleaders known as the
media mob they are completely shameless
now together they have lied to this
country about trump-russia collusion
they have ignored hillary clinton's
dirty
russian disinformation dossier the
democratic party the media they together
ignored abuse in the fisa courts they
ignored hunter biden's laptop just weeks
before the 2020 election
that could have been relevant and could
have had an impact on that election
russian disinformation they made it up
it turned out all to be true
they ignored the real quid pro quo with
joe biden holding out a billion taxpayer
dollars unless they fired a prosecutor
investigating his zero experienced son
making millions in ukraine uh they
ignored joe's lies about i never one
time talked to hunter about his foreign
business dealings now we have a phone
call from 2018 he was denying ever
talking to him about it uh in
all through 2020. the media mob they
echo every lie of the democratic party
they protect the democrats at all costs
at all times remember they told us
yesterday this was an emergency hearing
we have shocking game changing new
information brought forward by a white
house staffer named cassidy hutchinson
but that wasn't true this was not an
emergency hearing at all this was not
breaking new information in fact the
committee actually we discovered
interviewed ms hutchinson on tape on
four separate occasions prior to the
testimony now they have known about her
claims for months but apparently they
never got around to corroborating any of
them which is pretty weird because
hutchinson's claims we now have
discovered her hearsay claims like for
example her wild story about trump
physically assaulting two secret service
agents while trying to
commandeer the presidential limo the
beast as they call it and drive it to
the capitol himself now tonight we're
learning that the committee never even
one time reached out and did their due
diligence to the secret service to ever
verify
that far-fetched claim and now the two
agents involved are prepared according
to every news report pretty much to
testify under oath that the story told
yesterday is not true and never happened
but none of that matters to committee
member jamie raskin take a look
have you corroborated from other
witnesses that president trump grabbed
the steering wheel in that limousine and
got into an altercation with his lead
agent
well cassidy hutchinson
is an entirely credible witness
she testified under oath in front of the
entire country everyone was able to
judge uh her demeanor uh she has no
motivation or interest in lying in any
way and so what we have on the other
hand is uh some anonymously sourced
rumors of feelings of particular agents
look anybody who wants to testify can
come forward and testify under oath
about what happened all we're interested
in
is the truth
in other words uh no they didn't
corroborate the story at all nor do they
really seem to care by the way
hutchinson does in fact have a
motivation uh to smear donald trump
because we can break news tonight
according to two separate sources that i
have now spoken to this should have been
disclosed yesterday hutchinson was
desperate to work for
then soon to be former president trump
and we have confirmed that in fact she
did work for donald trump after the
election in his post-presidency
washington d.c office for several months
to be exact from january 21st to april 9
2021. now keep in mind that is well
after january 6 2021 but now suddenly
she is so deeply impacted by january 6
she had to speak out okay
now about her story about trump
assaulting the secret service it's not
the only part of her testimony that is
under scrutiny there are also serious
questions about a letter presented as
evidence during yesterday's testimony
you may remember take a look
ms hutchinson could you look at the
exhibit that we're showing on the screen
now
have you seen this note before
that's a note that i wrote at the
direction of the chief of staff on
january 6 likely around three o'clock
and it's written on the chief of staff
note card but that's your handwriting ms
hutchinson that's my handwriting
all right we have a little problem
according to former trump attorney eric
hershman she did not write that letter
he claims he did he claims that's his
handwriting not her handwriting now one
of them is telling the truth and one of
them is not now if she's lying about the
letter we need to know and by the way we
can easily ascertain the truth in this
but again the committee doesn't care
they put out a statement that claimed
quote the committee has done its
diligence on this and found ms
hutchinson's account of this matter is
credible
what diligence did you do exactly now if
this is such an important committee
presenting such important evidence to
the american people i don't know whose
handwriting it is i'll be honest the
committee that never asked the secret
service uh about her story why not get
follow the science we'll use the
democrats favorite line follow the
science bring in handwriting experts and
let them verify the handwriting on the
letter is it his or is it hers keep in
mind during a legitimate proceeding well
covering up exculpatory evidence that
would be considered deeply unethical and
would usually end the case right then
and there or if it's found out later
that would overturn a guilty verdict for
example if this was a legitimate
proceeding with all sides being heard
well we'd hear from that handwriting
expert we'd also hear these critical
facts take a look
calling up the guard and then it became
at the chain of command went to nancy
pelosi and to the mayor of d.c muriel
bowser did you as required by law
authorize that
uh 100
and attested to by many people and they
turned it down
nancy pelosi turned it down mayor
bowser's written refusal the
communications between the leader of the
capitol police and their chain of
command to the dod refusing our request
to allow national guardsmen and women to
stage on january 4 and 5 before january
6. did you both ask for the national
guard to be called up
without a doubt sean we've made that
very clear not just once but on numerous
occasions we wanted to make sure that
there was plenty of national guard on
the ready
in case there was some kind of violence
i had a meeting with president trump on
the third of january concerning some
international threats and at the very
end he asked if there were any requests
for national guard support what was the
president's response to you
with regard to the request made by mayor
bowser
fill it and do whatever was necessary to
protect the
demonstrators
so as you just heard four of the five
people we now have on tape present
during that meeting in the oval office
on january the fourth then president
trump authorized up to twenty thousand
national guard troops to be available
they were never called up by pelosi or
d.c mayor bowser as the law requires
because they get jurisdiction president
trump did his part then the jurisdiction
goes to them they didn't do their part
if this was a legitimate committee and
wanted to prevent this from ever
happening again they would demand the
emails the call logs all text messages
from speaker pelosi mayor bowser who
sent a letter by the way preemptively
declining national guard support
we'd also get
phone records from the house
sergeant-at-arms and texts and emails
and the sergeant-at-arms in the senate i
believe he passed away god rest her soul
chuck schumer by the way
we get all of his information the
capitol police chief who requested the
national guard six separate times but
was turned down by the capitol security
officials why hasn't he been called in
before national tv you know we'd also
like to hear from the secret service
agents that we referenced that were
referenced yesterday during testimony
we'd like to hear from the handwriting
experts whose handwriting was it
hershman's or hers and other key
witnesses of course that's never going
to happen because this is not a
legitimate committee this is critical
because it destroys the entire
predetermined narrative that donald
trump wanted violence was happy about
the violence encouraged the violence and
the committee with all their selective
self-serving editing
still refuses to show in the hearings
what donald trump also said during that
rally this
i know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the capitol building
to peacefully and
patriotically make your voices heard
that would be called more exculpatory
evidence that the committee refuses to
show you the american people and others
20 calling up ahead of time 20 000
troops sounds like he cared more than
bowser and pelosi about safety at the
capitol and they don't care about the
truth either these are just a bunch of
sad pathetic politicians that are
obsessed with all things donald trump
they yearn to be relevant and look at
this committee look at look who's on
this committee jeremy raskin he himself
once contested the results of the 2016
election he attempted to block donald
trump's certification along with 10
other democrats oh wow one might
conclude he's an insurrectionist himself
in 2004 the chairman of the january 6
committee that guy benny thompson
attempted to do the same thing with
president bush wow what about him
now all of a sudden they care about
accepting all elections results no
questions asked i wonder how many people
on the committee are supporting stacey
abrams and then there's the least honest
person in the entire washington swamp
which is saying something that guy the
congenital liar adam schiff one of the
biggest russian collusion truthers in
the entire world he told everyone he
possessed top secret evidence proving
donald trump's collusion with russia
well that never materialized except of
him on tape with a russian prankster
saying they had compromising matpate
deals on donald trump and he was
scheming to get them and all of this by
the way so-called evidence has been
debunked why because adam schiff is
nothing but a congenital liar and that
brings us now to congresswoman liz
cheney oh look at that right there
pictured with a warm embrace with
yesterday's star witness here hugging a
prior witness several days ago now quick
question we're just supposed to sit back
and accept all of the anti-trump
rhetoric by all the trump impeachers not
one
person that has a different point of
view on this committee was supposed to
just take everything as pure gospel
truth a committee by the way that who is
apparently very close with the witnesses
a committee with members who never
accepted the results of the 2016
election and other elections a committee
without any dissent without any
pro-trump republicans a committee
purposely leaving out critical testimony
of donald trump's efforts to protect the
capital with national guard troops
before crowds ever showed up in dc
especially he was smart in light of the
574 riots where let's see dozens of
americans died and thousands of cops
were injured and billions of property
damage that seemed like a wise and
prudent thing to do
jim jim jordan jim banks will join us in
a minute they were not allowed on the
committee they were kicked off the
committee why because the committee
doesn't care about the whole truth and
nothing but the truth it doesn't care
about ethics it doesn't care about real
justice it doesn't care about making the
capital more secure the committee only
cares about smearing trump and trying to
make it impossible for him to ever run
again hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else